I I've I've worked with thousands of men
in my private practice and in my
consultations and men fall in love with
strippers men fall in love with
prostitutes men fall in love with women
with personality disorders every single
day why is that is it because these
women love them so much is it because
they're kind is it because they're
supportive or
virtuous no it's because they [__] these
men to the point where their brains
start to
melt okay and when a man has brain
melting face
skewing life-altering sex it's like a
drug and it's like all that that guy can
think about and that guy isn't going to
just hit and quit a woman who does the
freaky nasty [__] for him because he
knows he can't get that on any street
corner
I think the question all men want to
know it's a very basic one is what do
women
want it's a very heavy one there's a lot
to it right there is a lot to that that
was the greatest mystery to Freud and
the fathers of
psychology the true and unsatisfying
answer is women want what they
want
and the secondary to that is women want
what other women want often women want
what other women want more than they
want what's best for themselves this has
to do with the fact that both men and
women are playing two different games
simultaneously both sexes are playing
their own
intrasexual status games and they're
also playing intersexual power games and
it's very difficult
for a man to win both of those games or
a woman to win both of those games
simultaneously for instance uh a man
could potentially s powerfully for a
woman and be at her beck and call and
yes dear sweetheart and buy her flowers
and roses and that might
work in the short term to attract a
woman into a relationship but that man
isn't going to be elevated in status
within his own intersexual hierarchy so
other men aren't really going to look at
that
behavior um admiringly
admiringly and that's going to be
potentially a liability for that person
by the same token a lot of modern women
are in this trap where some of the
behavior that might work to get them the
kind of relationship they want from the
men they want to have that relationship
with is frowned upon by their fellow
woman it's basically the equivalent of
sing in men and the equivalent of sing
in men for women is anything that has to
do with let's say traditional
reactionary feminine
behavior that I am going to be
submissive for a man that I am going
to wait for him that's how it used to be
where a woman what was that in the
Odyssey where Penelope waited for 20
years for odys to come home and all of
the suitors of Greece had taken over her
house and she still refused to believe
that
odyusa that I'm going to serve a man or
make his life easier or do any kind of
domestic help all of these things would
be seen as almost a betrayal of her
gender at this point and so even though
those behaviors might instrumentally
help her get the kind of relationship
she wants with the man she wants to have
that relationship
with it would come at the cost of let's
say the respect of the women that she's
competing against in her own intersexual
status games so this is kind of how we
get into our own ways these
days Allan you have a YouTube channel
called psych hacks which is uh I believe
is going to
be it's going to be the hottest YouTube
channel in the world I think I I think
it's just the most fascinating thing
I've ever seen on YouTube uh one of your
talks is on
how uh how is the titled any woman can a
woman can get any man she
wants how to get any man you want yes
and it's geared towards women there are
three three steps to that right mm talk
talk to me about about that sure first
of all I'll go a little bit more what I
say in those three videos because this
is important there are two general
approaches to dating and I call them
hunting and fishing hunting is where you
can Target a very specific person for a
potential relationship and you know
pursue that one person fishing is more
or less you cast a wide net and you
develop optionality and and you choose
the best option that also has already
chosen you and I think it's actually in
most women's best interests to hunt
women can hunt in the dating Market much
better than men
can this is due to the fact that there
is an enormous asymmetry between men and
women's openness to a sexual
relationship I'm going to take a little
bit detour I'm going to get back to your
question uh one of my all-time favorite
psychological studies took place on a
college campus a few decades ago and the
researchers were trying to examine men
and women's differential attitudes
towards casual sex and what they did is
they got a attractive young college man
and an attractive young college woman
and they basically memorized the same
script and went up to members of the
opposite sex on campus and the script
was basically like hey I've seen you
around school I think you're very
attractive would you like to come to bed
with me something like that um women are
always saying I want an honest guy I
want a guy to tell me what his true
intentions are this is about as honest
and true as a guy can get how
many women do you
think responded Yes to that Overture oh
they they're all going to say no
100% 100% of the women approached
that's a 0% success rate said they were
not interested in fact many of them got
offended and angry at the the
supposition and what happened with the
woman when the woman approached men 75%
said yes only 75 well that's probably
because the other 25% were looking for
where the hidden camera was because this
was such a strange and unusual
circumstance they knew that something
was up about this and so they probably
their spidey sense was tingling and so
they you know they holstered it and did
the socially acceptable response that's
my interpretation anyway so the fact of
the matter is is that most women could
just go up to a guy and offer to
initiate a sexual relationship and she
is overwhelmingly likely to get a
positive response now women generally
respond well Orion that's just sex I
don't want to just have a sexual
relationship with a guy I want to have
an emotional relationship I want to have
a committed relationship and I say okay
that's that's fine
but how else are you going to get the
foot in the door it's like you have to
understand women that sex is like the
Trojan horse that gets you into the
gates of the city that's what allows men
to open up and let you in now if they
let you in and then they just kick you
out well that was a blown opportunity
like you once you're in there are things
that you can and should do to stay there
but you can't do those things until he
lets you in and the way to be let in to
the gates of the city is to
provide a sexual opportunity and most
men are willing to have sex with most
women whereas the converse is certainly
not true that's why women can hunt and
that's why women should hunt they should
Target specific men they should do their
research they should try to do as much
stalking you know broadly defined on
their target as possible they need to
know who is this guy what is he like
what is he not like what are his foibles
what's his reputation like the more
information that she has the more that
she can bait her hook with for that
particular man and of course the most
succulent juicy bait is a sexual
opportunity okay so once woman has
decided that this is the man that she
would like to Target for a
relationship there's a few things that
she has to do one is she needs to make
it clear that she is open to a sexual
relationship that she is not going to
put up much resistance at
all there's there's a kind of an art to
this if a woman just kind of goes up to
a guy and says uh I'm yours that's going
to be kind of unusual and it's going to
make the guy potentially
standoffish um so women have to like put
themselves in front of the guy just like
in olden days where they would kind of
drop the handkerchief and bend over and
the guy would be like H my lucky day you
know it's we often think of men
initiating but often women initiate the
initiation you understand
um and if a woman is just waiting for a
guy to do that and she's not initiating
the
initiation I don't have a lot of
sympathy because she has this
she's sitting on this incredible gender
specific success rate uh that has to do
with initiation okay so a woman needs to
make it clear that she is open to a
sexual relationship with a guy because
that's the Trojan Horse to get into the
City and in general to keep a
man it's important for a woman to not
just offer a sexual opportunity but to
be the nastiest [__] version of
herself possible and and there's a
number of good reasons for why this is
true first of all and and foremost
men whether or not it's true but it's
mostly true men gauge a woman's interest
and attraction in him by what she is
willing to do with him sexually it's
been very well documented and I think
all men understand this on like a gut
level that women will do more
things faster with in the bedroom with
men that they like and they're attracted
to than with men that they are not and
so when a woman is the nastiest
[__] version of herself possible
what she's functionally communicating
with her behavior which is the only
thing that really matters not with her
words but with her actions that you are
the most desirable man I've ever met and
I am willing to break the rules for you
that I strongly and rigidly enforc with
all other men and that's going to play
to a man's ego absolutely which is a
trap for men but women should absolutely
use that to their advantage whenever
possible I mean All is fair in Love and
War right uh that's going to make the
man feel like he's a king of the
bdis uh he's going to feel like and it's
going to put him in his
masculine all good things because when a
man is put into his masculine and he
feels that there is a beautiful woman
who is sexually submissive to him it
triggers his instinct to protect and to
provide which how does that not redound
to the woman's benefit you know what I'm
saying it's actually a very easy
Con on the part of the women I don't I
don't know a guy they wouldn't fall for
that it's it's very hard to do man
so uh by being the nastiest [__]
version of of yourself possible women
are communicating that I'm willing to to
break the rules for you because I'm
putting you above all other men which is
going to make stimulate his ego and put
him into that position now that's also
going to keep him coming back you have
to understand
that one of my very first episodes years
ago was everyone is unique and everyone
is replaceable both of those things are
true that's one of the paradoxes of
being alive you are a unique individual
No One Like You has ever existed before
and will never exist again but once
you're gone people will be making
interviews like this and PE and and once
I'm gone people will be sitting here
answering questions like this and that's
how the whole game continues forever and
thank God for that or else everything
would come crumbling down on some level
so bad for the individual but good for
society and the perpetuation of the game
let's put it that
way
so if a woman simply provides a
run-of-the-mill sexual opportunity
that's very easy to
replace and the fact of the matter is is
that sex in today's Marketplace is
extremely cheap it's cheap
because sex must now preced
commitment there's a whole other Spiel I
can give you about why that's the case
but let's table that for now because I
still want to answer your question
that's changed since our parents
generation perhaps it's certain it's
changed in the last 60 years and the
main instigator of the change was birth
control two minute sidebar the reason
why commitment had to precede sex for so
long is because the threat of pregnancy
always loomed
large
and in that day it was extremely
difficult if not impossible for a woman
to earn her own
money and to survive in society without
the pro protection or provision of a man
or a governmental program that served as
its surrogate and all of those things
have changed the reason why commit
commitment was required before sex was
because the stakes of a woman becoming
pregnant outside of marriage were
extremely high and it was upheld
socially because if that man couldn't be
persuaded or coerced to commit then that
single unwed mother and her children
would have become society's problem so
all of these things have changed women
can and do earn their own money there
are all kinds of governmental programs
to subsidize single mothers men whether
they commit to this Arrangement or not
are legally required to give women child
support uh for the children that they
sire in some cases even for the children
that they don't so the circumstances for
requiring commitment prior to sex have
shifted and one once a few women started
to be okay with a sexual relationship
prior to an exclusive commitment or
marriage once a critical mass was
reached
then functionally all other women had to
do the same in order to remain
competitive within the sexual
Marketplace because in today's day and
age if a woman were if you were to go
out in the first date with a woman she
were to insist well I'm not going to
have sex until I get married especially
if she's not a virgin
uh I mean she's going to price herself
out of the sexual Marketplace that's
going to be too expensive for any given
man when there's a woman two swipes away
who's going to be willing to go home
with him for a drink or two so that's
the situation that we live in For Better
or For Worse so sex is kind of the
standard we used to say why buy the cow
if you can get the milk for free right
well that presumes
that milk wasn't being freely
distributed in the pasture but now that
milk is freely being distributed in the
pasture you have to give milk not
because milk will motivate anyone to
make the sale but because not providing
milk is going to be an a strange absence
it's going to it's going to be more
expensive for the buyer in a way that
none of the competitors are requiring
okay so this is the world that we live
in For Better or For Worse so when women
provide a sexual opportunity it's a good
idea to not just be a run-of-the bill
sexual opportunity because let me tell
you I've I've worked with thousands of
men in my private practice and in my
consultations and men fall in love with
strippers men fall in love with
prostitutes men fall in love with women
with personality disorders every single
day why is that
is it because these women love them so
much is it because they're kind is it
because they're supportive or
virtuous no it's because they [__] these
men to the point where their brains
start to
melt okay and when a man has brain
melting face
ske life-altering sex it's like a drug
and it's like all that that guy can
think about and that guy isn't going to
just hit and quit a woman who does the
freaky nasty [__] for him because he
knows he can't get that on any Street
Corner that's the second time I've
laughed in 8,000
interviews the first time was last week
so I mean does this make sense to you it
makes perfect sense okay
so the they used to say that the weight
to a man's heartest through his stomach
it's actually just a few inches lower
and there's no
reason why I mean all these are are like
Behavior AV there's no reason why a non
stripper SL prostitute SL borderline
couldn't learn to do some of the things
in the bedroom that these women tend to
do and to get men obsessed with them
okay so once you target a man and you
provide the sexual opportunity and
you're the nasti [__] version of
yourself then you have an in like you're
within the city
and you're you're not going to be kicked
out anytime soon you're not going to be
pumped and dumped if you an
amazing over-the-top sexual experience
okay it's very very
important and you don't want to do this
with everybody because that just is a
race to the bottom too because it
becomes harder and harder to be the
nastiest [__] version of yourself
if you're that with every single guy
that's why you have to do your homework
and you want to hunt and you want to
Target specific men be selective it's
important to be very select itive as a
woman because men have all a very
understandable but from a woman's
perspective extremely frustrating double
standard with respect to female Chastity
Chastity is something that they would
highly prize in a wife and don't want to
see anything in a casual lover but the
fact of the matter is that the pathway
to become a wife for the vast majority
of women is through the Casual lover
route most women will see this happening
they'll be with a guy casually for some
months maybe even some years and then
the guy will catch feelings usually guys
it takes a little bit longer for them to
catch feelings and then they'll start to
ask questions how many guys you've been
with you know what's your family like
Patrice O'Neal had this great joke once
where his girlfriend had been with him
for seven years and he had been with her
for four like it took 3 years for him to
kind of like see that woman as his
girlfriend you know and that's when the
relationship begins to shift and that's
when the guy starts to become a little
bit more possessive potentially you know
don't go out to the club or why are you
dressed like that they're not going to
act like that on the first date they're
just looking to smash right so the fact
of the matter is most men don't show up
on first dates thinking oh please please
Jesus alab Buddha make this the last
date I ever have to go on I'm ready for
the one I'm ready for my wife I want to
settle down
today they're looking they're thinking I
hope she mostly looks like her pictures
and she lets me Smash that's what most
guys are thinking and so to get and and
and a lot of women when they show up to
their first date they're not thinking I
sure hope this guy just buys me a couple
drinks uses me sexually and never calls
me
again you know and
yet that can happen right so it's
like most women don't show up on a date
thinking or expecting that they're going
to go back to a guy's house
and have sex and yet that happens every
like all the time right why because that
guy had a plan that guy had some game
and that guy was moving the interaction
in the direction of that kind of
relationship the same thing happens for
the committed relationships that women
want they don't just happen they happen
because a woman had a plan she had some
game and she was guiding the
relationship in the direction of that
kind of
encounter very few guys are going to
give
that uh voluntarily just like very few
women are just handing out sex to guys
just because they want it right wanting
is free it costs nothing to want things
my wanting sex from women has never
persuaded any single woman to give it to
me in my entire life why would a woman
wanting commitment or marriage or
exclusivity or Etc why should that
motivate me in and of itself to give
that to her like there has has to be
some back and forth there has to be
some strategy and there has to be some
uh the value proposition has to make
sense so to boil down the transaction
that's hopefully taking place the woman
is looking for a commitment and uh a
better lifestyle MH and the man is
looking for an attractive sexual partner
most guys don't get beyond that that's
right they're like I just I wanted to
have sex that's why I called you up you
looked hot and event hopefully they
develop feelings often not always not
always but yeah I mean what did Hannah
Lector say we covet what we see every
day so it's like you and there's the
psychological term for that I think is
the mere exposure effect which is the
well-documented
phenomenon that people just feel more
positively towards people Brands ideas
that they see every day that's part of
why marketing works is that
if I give you two Brands and you've
heard of this one and you haven't heard
of this one you're going to feel more
positively disposed towards this one
just because you're familiar with it in
fact a great deal of dating and the
emotion attached to that is really just
familiarity as opposed to let's say
love but I digress okay so a woman's in
she's now being the nasty [__] version
of herself so how can she convert that
into the kind of relationship that she
wants the key key it to stay there the
key to deepen the intimacy of that
relationship Beyond um pure sexual
Dynamic is for the woman to become
useful she has to be of use to the man
in order to justify her introduction
into increasingly intimate Circles of
his lifestyle so let's go out in the
limb and say that the men that the women
are generally targeting for their
relation ships are not just like Schmo
who are sleeping on the couch in their
parents' basement these are generally
guys who are successful who are rich who
are high status who have prestigious
professions maybe they're famous like
these women weren't there for this guy's
struggles they weren't there for when he
was upand coming they're targeting him
now because of his fully extrapolated
lifestyle style okay that's basically
the biggest bait that men can use to
attract women is
Lifestyle the joke is basically that men
want the Barbie
doll that's it you know we we'll take
the clothes off and just we want the
doll don't tell me the name don't tell
me the story we just want the doll and
what women want is all the [__] the kend
doll comes with that's why there's
Cowboy Ken and there's stock broker Ken
and there's Malibu Stacy Ken and they'll
throw the Ken away and they'll just play
with the accessories in the
Dreamhouse and that's why the gendered
complaints always fall along the lines
of the man is just using me the woman
for
sex and the woman is just using me the
man for my resources and won't even [__]
me I have never ever in my life heard a
woman complain to me I pay for the house
I pay for the car I gave him the kids
that he wanted and he still won't touch
me I've never heard that not even once
and I've never heard a man complain that
he was just being used by a woman
sexually I sometimes in my past I've
wondered if I just wasn't attractive
enough to be used sexually by a woman I
mean I I think it might even
be kind of a refreshing uh change of
pace and that's an interesting failure
intersexual understanding that men don't
often see the problem of being sexually
objectified because they think it's a
compliment but I can see how it would be
uncomfortable for women to be sexually
objectified by men that they don't want
to be sexually objectified by so once
you're in you want to be useful this guy
has been targeted by you because he's
got a lot going on don't create problems
for him because the more
you rock the boat the more time energy
and attention he has to take away from
everything that's
working which is why you're there is to
enjoy the extrapolated
lifestyle to focus on you so don't rock
the boat don't make any unnecessary
problems and then look around like open
your eyes open your ears listen to the
guy the guy will tell you all the time
where he's struggling where he still
needs assistance where his bottlenecks
happen to be and then just start to help
him just start to help him if if you see
that something needs to be done and no
one else is doing it congrad your
[__] lation you've just been elected
you know and why would you do this
because I know a lot of women out there
are thinking ran this is a terrible idea
I'm going to have to like what am I
getting out of all this I have to do all
this stuff for a man well what you're
getting out of this is job security
because the idea here is once you start
to do things in an instrumental way that
are necessary for the maintenance and
the propagation of this man's lifestyle
you become essentially indispensable to
the whole Machinery it's would be very
difficult or painful to extricate you
from all of the good stuff that that guy
has
that's
where he's vulnerable where he needs
help because if you show up that's an
don't see that as like a chore see that
as an opportunity oh I'll take care of
that that's great um because it gives
you one more like purchase into that
life if you can take care of that it's
going to be very very difficult to get
rid of you and it also means that you're
going to be around more and more and
you're going to be privy to increasingly
levels of intimacy in his
lifestyle and that's basically how you
achieve de facto commitment and
exclusivity from a man and you're
integrating yourself into his life and
you're also the best sexual partner he's
probably ever had that man is never
going to [__] leave you if you [__]
his brains out don't cause problems and
help
him men are not difficult like you can
get any man that you want and keep him
if you do those things he could be a
millionaire he could be a billionaire he
could be an athlete he could be a
celebrity he could be a neurosurgeon you
could be a rock star whatever floats
your boat that's what you do but there's
still one thing a woman can do to screw
it up yes so women got in touch with me
and they said Orion I tried all those
things and it still didn't work and I
believe them some women do do those
things I mean there are certainly some
women out there I mentioned some of them
who know exactly what sexual buttons to
push a man to turn him into
jelly and they are great with let's say
the love bombing and they show up and
they overd deliver with what they're
willing to do in the context of that
relationship maybe they don't do it
quite long enough
to really be fully integrated into his
lifestyle but they do those
things a lot of women unfortunately can
snatch
defeat from the jaws of
success by doing one
thing and that one thing is
disrespecting men this is what I call
the unbreakable rule a woman can never
ever
ever allow herself to disrespect the man
that she wants to be in a long-term
committed relationship
with and there's a number of reasons for
that but one of the least appreciated
ones
is that if a woman
allows herself to disrespect this man
and he allows that as well then over
time the dynamic of that relationship
will shift to the point where that woman
is functionally with a shell of a
man that is no longer a person that she
can respect or be attracted to and
that's generally when she looks for the
the door so disrespecting a man usually
provokes conflict which rocks the boat
which goes against the things that I was
talking about earlier and it decreases a
woman's own attraction for a man
especially if he doesn't respond
effectively um
and what do they say in the Bible it's
like a a a wise woman builds her house
with her hands and tears it down
my ellipses with her mouth it's like a
lot of women will open their mouth and
talk their way out of the relationship
that they could have had with the men
who actually wanted to have it with them
and they do this because in the moment
they might be frustrated or
impatient so it's emotional regulation
and self
soothing uh women also disres ECT men in
less obvious ways I mean obvious ways
are verbal abuse criticism physical
abuse
um mocking especially in front of other
people but a woman can also disrespect a
man by demanding
explanations by interrogating
him these are forms of disrespect
because they play inappropriately with
power differentials
the right to demand an explanation the
right to ask questions always goes from
the high to the low it never goes the
other way
around just think about the military if
I were your commanding officer and I
called you in and I told you about a
mission you wouldn't have the right to
ask me a bunch of questions before you
decided whether you were going to accept
the mission you know um you that would
be insubordination and it wouldn't be
tolerated
so there is a way to get the kind of
information that you want from a man
without interrogating without shaming
without
demanding you do not have to always
agree with a man that would be
impossible because Men We Men do all
kinds of boneheaded things all [__]
time so women do not have to approve of
a guy but they absolutely have to find
ways to disapprove
disagree without disrespecting and
that's absolutely something that can be
possible
the general rule of thumb is if you
wouldn't say
that in that way to your boss if you
were interested in keeping your job you
shouldn't say that to a
man so that was some great advice for
the women what do men need to provide in
order to find the woman they want it
seems the ability to provide a better
lifestyle is the number one thing a
woman is looking for right oh generally
yes so women treat men the way men treat
jobs
and this will help men not take the
dating process as personally as they
might
otherwise think of it this way you might
as a man have no problems at your
current employment you might feel that
you're perfectly happy there but if one
day a recruiter called up and said hey
Orion I got an offer for you would you
be interested in coming over to this
company will triple your salary we'll
give you unlimited paid time off we'll
give you a
promotion and we'll make sure that you
never have to work on any of the
projects you don't want to work on ever
again I'll take it you're at least going
to consider that offer strongly and the
vast majority of people are going to say
you know what there's no problem here
but I have to do this for my career and
that's what a lot of guys hear
especially when they're young when the
women break things off because in the
vast majority of cases that's what women
do they say something like you know you
were great I don't
have any complaints about this I just
have to do this for me this is something
that I need to do for myself right now
it's it's the same thing and everybody
will understand at that company that
this was the right move for your career
no one is going to say oh after all all
we've done for you it's like it's a
[__] job it's business and if that
person were in the same position he or
she would also have accepted the offer
as well so we don't need to get on our
high horse and pretend uh to a
righteousness that we probably don't
possess
so the best way to attract a woman is to
be a woman's best
offer to be a woman's best option
okay and this is no small small feet
because when you're 18 and you're a man
you have [__] all like it's extremely
difficult to be a young man in today's
society and it is not appreciated at all
in popular culture um it's very very
difficult because at 18 women don't want
you because you have nothing that women
want you don't have any wealth you don't
have any status you don't have any
emotional maturity you're not ready to
settle down and have kids you're useless
you're just a big throbbing Hardon and
you can't even use that to transact for
anything of interest for the woman and
you're kind of useless to men because
you have no skills you have no
experience you have no Mastery you're a
liability on the [__] team like I can
help you you can't help me God forbid I
have to fall cuz are you going to catch
me absolutely not so it's like young men
are double [__] they're at the the
lowest of the low of all of their status
hierarchies that they have to compete in
and they can be that way for 10 years
because it can take about that long to
develop an emotionally compelling
lifestyle that might
be the best option for a woman that that
man is authentically attracted
to okay so what do men have to do
it's it's they have to do a lot
and the first thing they have to do is
they have to learn how to
wait so this has to do with the let's
call it the normalized sexual
Marketplace values of men and women
according to the research
so women's normaliz sexual Marketplace
value Peaks at 18 years old and drops
precipitously from that day forward it
never rises again men's normaliz sexual
Marketplace value is lowest at 18 Gra
gradually Rises up until about 40
remains constant for about another 20
years and then slowly declines into old
age it isn't until 30 years old that the
average male sexual Marketplace value
exceeds the average woman's sexual
Marketplace value for the very first
time this means that women's default
action is to act like all things being
equal they will never be in a moment
where they can demand the relationship
they want from the man they want to have
it with then today because for the vast
majority of women this is when they're
going to have their highest valuation in
the sexual
Marketplace so their default is to
act on the other hand most men will
never be more disadvantaged in the
sexual Market Place than they are
today with each passing year they
accumulate more experience more wealth
more status more Prestige and these are
the things that are instrumentally
connected to women's attraction to men
so the first thing that men need to
learn how to do is to wait because it
could be a while it could be a while
before they can start to enjoy an
advantage in the sexual Marketplace and
most guys don't get there in the sense
that they commit and foreclose before
they experience that possibility
it's not a coincidence that the average
age at first marriage in this country is
29 remember I just said that 30 is the
day when or the the year when the sexual
Marketplace polarity switches for the
very first time and it never ever
returns so most marriages happen at the
last moment that a woman enjoys a power
differential over the man in the sexual
Marketplace this is the smartest [__]
thing that she could possibly do
because if she were to wait another year
or two she might not have been able to
get that same commitment even from that
same
man because she will have declined a
little bit and he will have gone and he
be like oh well wait a minute I'm
starting to get some options
here I'm I kind of feel attractive women
are kind of showing themselves that
they're interested in me maybe for the
very first time you know what I'm saying
but most men never get to a place where
they are more
attractive than most of the women that
they're dealing with and so they think
that it's almost like just a woman's
right or an innate privilege to have
that kind of Attraction it's it's not it
it's just a consequence of being in a
favorable moment in the sexual
Marketplace men don't always get there
they have to play their cards right but
they might get there eventually later in
life like a uh a division one athlete um
or a profession athlete a little bit
later in life
uh a partner at a prestigious Law Firm a
a politician these guys they understand
that because they've played their cars
right they have incredible optionality
with women these
days okay so men need to learn how to
wait so what do they have to but they
can't just sit there so that men have to
do three things really to become
attractive to women and these are things
that I am extrapolating in the context
of my metaphor for the sexual
Marketplace which is a big dock like a a
pier where all the ships Moore right is
that women are looking for a
captain and there are three things that
men have to do to become a Captain they
have to build a
boat they have to learn to sail and they
have to plot a
course build a boat learn to sale plot
of course and those three things can
take 10 years at least to do and if it's
going to take 10 years you might as well
get started right so build a boat is a
metaphor for your
lifestyle it's going to take two things
to build a boat resources because wood
ain't free and it's going to take
knowledge the the knowledge is a part
that doesn't get a lot of airtime in
today's society everyone's thinking
about the money money is extremely
important but if you don't have
knowledge about how money Works you're
not going to be able to keep the money
if your fool ass actually looks out is
able to get it you know if if you don't
understand what women are and how they
operate you're not going to be able to
keep one if you actually have the Good
Fortune to attract one into your life do
you understand so the knowledge that
we're looking for is awareness for how
reality actually works not how we want
it to work not how we think it should
work not how our society tells us it's
supposed to look but how it actually
works because if we can understand the
principles and the laws by which reality
operates we can flow with those
currents and we won't be vulnerable when
we're out on the Open Sea so we need
resources and we need the knowledge and
experience to be able to maintain all
those good things that we
built indefinitely because what's the
point in taking a a castle if we can't
keep it
right um then we have to learn how to
sail which is the development of some
kind of Mastery or
expertise the fact of the matter is that
women want successful guys and
successful men are not necessarily
virtuous
men they're not necessarily good men
they're not necessarily the best men or
Nice
Guys the fact of the matter is that that
successful men are men that other people
want things
from that's it successful men are
successful to the extent that lots of
people want things from them the more
people want things from you the more
successful you are as a man if nobody
wants anything from you no one will give
you the [__] time of day if you're a
guy that's just how is now this is the
flip side of the male this is the male
experience to the equivalent to
the let's say the sexual objectification
that women complain about and experience
oh men just want to [__] me it's like
yeah kind of and if they didn't they
wouldn't be talking to you the flips the
equivalent of that is well these women
just want things from me it's like yeah
but if they didn't they wouldn't be
talking to you dude so it's
like pick your poison we both have have
our struggles to deal with but
ultimately we have to be useful to
others and a successful man has
developed a
solution for a problem that many people
have and those people will line up with
dollars in their hand to hand it over to
that guy for that solution okay so this
could be anything from being a
successful Community plumber to being a
uh a a startup entrepreneur with the
next app that's going to solve a a
social crisis um it it could be anything
but you need to be able to solve many
people's problems and many people will
need to want things from you in order to
be successful that's learning how to
sail and the third component is plotting
a course this is really important is
every man needs to have an overarching
mission to his
life um this is important because
because when we're out in the open sea
it's where there are no features of land
it's very easy to get
lost and how did The Navigators of old
Traverse the wastes by looking at the
stars because the Stars relative to the
earth move in very fixed
patterns we also will be blown off
course by currents and weather and if we
don't have a star to Sail by it's going
to be very difficult to get ourselves
back on course and we can't get oursel
back on course if we of course we never
had a course to begin with so the
overarching mission to a man's life also
prevents him from doing stupid things
with respect to women like making women
the center of his life the the fastest
way to lose a woman is to make her the
center of your
life because women want a guy who's on
his [__] he wants they want a guy with
ambition with drive with purpose they
don't want to be that ambition drive or
purpose they want to be next to the guy
with those things and to enjoy the
fruits of all of that ambition drive and
purpose but if the woman becomes the
ambition drive and purpose then
functionally the whole operation begins
to fall
apart and this also helps a guy to
resist the urge to appease in moments of
crisis with a woman because it can very
much happen in the course of a
relationship where an unhappy woman
might make certain unreasonable demands
of a man either you you you work too
much you spend too much time at work so
either you need to spend more time at
home or I'm walking for instance well of
course him working so much is part of
the reason why she was attracted to him
to begin with him working so much is
what what got him the money and the
houses and the reputation that made it
likely that she chose him over all her
other
options she doesn't say when she goes
out to dinner or on vacations or when
she drives her car that it's too bad
that the guy works so
much and if this man in that moment were
to cater to that
woman's
demand and he were to lose both his
professional reputation and success and
the relationship he would deserve it
that would be his
foyble and that's where men are mostly
weak is they a lot of guys find it very
difficult to stand up to a woman's
negative emotionality whether it's their
anger and their
upsetness or their tears or their guilt
tripping or their
shaming all men it seems have an
emotional THB screw there's like one
emotion for whatever reason is
particularly difficult for them to
bear and if a woman sticks around you
long enough she's going to figure out
what that emotion
is and if she twists the screw on that
particular emotion and you bend and you
appease and
you change as a consequence of
attempting to avoid that temporary pain
and discomfort of coming into contact
with that unpreferred
emotion what you will do is create a
monster in your relationship because
you'd be training this woman
unconsciously to know that whenever she
really needed to get what she wanted all
she had to do was hurt you in this way
and she loses respect she loses
respect and the guy feels even less
appreciated as well because she be can
she often doesn't even want the thing
that she's demanding in that
moment
so it's it's just not a a
bad it's a it's a very bad idea let's
put it that
way so that's what men have to do to
attract a woman they have to build a
ship which is to develop an extrapolated
interesting emotionally compelling
lifestyle they have to learn to sale
which is they have to develop expertise
and skills that are of use to other
people and they have to plot a course
they need to have an overarching mission
to their life something that is more
important to them
than I guess anything else really it has
to be more important than anything else
if it's not then a woman will figure out
what that other thing will be
and that will be your
downfall that will be your
downfall so you've told us what women
can do to get the man they want and
you've told us what men could do to get
the women they want but there's more to
it isn't there of course the game oh
yeah the game is
infinite I can be a wealthy handsome man
with a great future sitting at a bar on
Saturday
night and nothing's going to happen for
me right correct especially if you're a
man if you are a decently attractive
woman and you were to sit by yourself at
a bar on a Saturday night whether you
wanted it or not you would soon have
company but a man could be brilliant he
could be rich he could be a
neurosurgeon and he could drink by
himself all night okay so men
need game in the the sense of they need
to put on they need some strategy in
order to attract the opposite sex that's
very different from the strategies that
women do I'm not going to say that women
don't have to do that they do all kinds
of things to their appearance right
because that's generally what's most
important to men especially on first
blush with respect to their attraction
to women so they do all kinds of things
with respect to their figure and their
dress and their fashion and their makeup
and things like that men For Better or
For Worse we don't really have to worry
about that as much so there are a few
different strategies that consistently
work to increase your attraction as a
man to women let's see if I can remember
them
um cocky and playful is a is an old
standby from the pickup
Community
um being like this is a tough one it's
not the best one but being like funny
being the funny guy can work like
there's um but it can also backfire
because at some point you do have to
kind of transition from being kind of
like Goofy and playful to being sexual
and sometimes that can feel like a bait
and switch to a woman Patrice O'Neal
used to say I wish I didn't have to
laugh my way into [__] but that was
what he had to do
apparently
um there
is also like low low activation game
which is just sort of like confidence
and not giving a woman much uh
energy that works if you already have
let's say some reputation buyin if you
have a a table in the VIP bottle section
of a club for instance you already have
some social validation that you have the
money to spend on that
so you don't necessarily have to work as
hard to attract attention to yourself
because like you did that passively with
respect to your structure and so you can
actually kind of be a little bit more
aloof and withdrawn which makes you
potentially seem even more attractive in
that moment
right uh but the essence of game is to
stimulate an emotional reaction in a
woman that
is the the easiest way to seduce a woman
is to stimulate an emotional response in
her um and it doesn't even really matter
what the emotion is it doesn't even have
to be a positive emotion I mean that's
why negging works on some
level um which is disrespecting it's a
it's a teasing playful disrespecting yes
it's sort of like treating a girl like
your bratty little
sister so it's not it should be anyway a
real coldhearted
harsh um disrespect it should be playful
playful the idea here is is that I'm so
confident in your presence that I can I
can kind of toy with your beauty that I
know will Dazzle and stun and petrify
other men I it has no effect on me
confidence goes a long way confidence is
amazing so one of the things that a lot
of guys don't
understand so I I've had many a few
different careers in my life so far I
used to be an actor and when I was an
actor as a young man it was easier for
me to get laid than when I was a rich
successful doctor it's changed a little
bit now that I'm somewhat famous but
until I started the YouTube channel and
it blew up it was much much harder for
me to get laid as a successful
entrepreneur doctor than being a broke
theater actor in New York
City
and this is baffling to guys but the
fact of the matter is is that you do not
need money to get
laid you might need money if you want to
get
married but you definitely don't need
money to get
laid and a lot of guys and it's a a kind
of a function of their male rational
mindset they listen to talks online or
they buy programs and they what do women
want and they say Okay women want abs
women want tall guys women want uh Rich
guys and they think okay well some of
those things I can do some of those
things I can't do so but it's like okay
I'll get the ABS check I'll get the
money check and so now all I have to do
is go up into in front of a woman and
say in so many ways just let know hey I
am a rich guy with abs and they're going
they're supposed to just like line up to
[__] them and let me tell you that
that's that's not how it works
um so I call those things attraction
proxies guys really want women to become
attracted to them they hear that these
things are what women in general want
and so they say well I'll just get those
things and then the attraction will be
taken care of and that's not true I do
all the time with guys who have super
Yachts down in Miami who fly private
jets and who cannot get [__] laid
because they have no experience picking
women up they don't know how to talk to
beautiful women in particular they don't
have any problems with the ones they're
not attracted to generally but obviously
that's not the ones that they
want the way to get laid is to learn how
to seduce a woman that's it like you
don't need ABS you don't need money what
you need is seduction technique and the
core of Seduction is the ability to
stimulate an emotional response in
somebody else and to guide them through
an emotional Journey that ultimately
culminates in a sexual
experience that you've more or less
curated for that
person there's a saying that goes a man
wants a good girl who's only bad with
him and a woman wants a bad boy who's
only good to her that's great yeah I
heard that one about a year ago it
resonated with me it's true why do women
love
[__] why do women love
[__]
well there's a number of reasons for
that and there are good
reasons first of all um an [__] is
generally somebody who doesn't care
about another person's feelings this
isn't my term this is a term that a lot
of guys use when they're when they're
losing
out I hear we can use that term [__]
I got no problem with asshol um but
let's break it down like what [__]
do get laid a lot they certainly get
laid over the nice guys so what are
[__] doing or or how are they being
with women that is allowing them to have
and enjoy greater success than the the
the nice guys out there well like I said
one of the first things about [__]
is they don't care how other people feel
and what did I just say a few minutes
ago is like the Achilles heal for most
men is the negative expressed emotion of
women I'm upset with you I'm angry with
you they start to cry it's like on some
level a nice guy will be too empathetic
will say oh I'm uncomfortable with This
Woman's distress I am going to change
myself I'm going to change the situation
I'm going to change the relationship I
will change reality itself if I can to
get this woman to stop crying or to get
this woman to stop being angry with me
without necessarily considering whether
or not this woman has a [__] point
whether her tears are Justified whether
her anger is
Justified like for better for worse men
and women can get angry inappropriately
maybe she's doing it just to see how
spineless you are it's possible I mean
we call those [__] tests right and a lot
of what happens in testing is
unconscious I I think that there are
some conscious intentional tests that
women will do towards men but I think
personally and professionally the
majority of testing occurs below the
threshold of awareness for
women so an [__] isn't vulnerable to
those displays because on some level he
doesn't give a [__] he says sweetheart
if you want to be upset with me that's
fine that's your you're
right why why do I need you to be upset
or to be not upset it's you're a full-
grown
adult like if you want to be angry if
you want to be out of sorts if you want
to be despondent and sulky hey no skin
off my back I don't have to feel those
feelings I felt them I know they're not
pleasant that's why I prefer not to
experience them but for whatever reason
you want to feel that way knock yourself
out sweetheart I'm not going to stand in
the way of you and your feelings and let
me tell you to the extent that those
feelings were instrumentally attempting
to change that man's behavior if a man
responds that way that emotion will
disappear very
quickly because it doesn't
work most things most people don't
persist in strategies that don't
work if someone persists in a strategy
it's because it at least partly
works the word dysfunction is mostly the
word function dysfunction is mostly
functional in that it gets what it wants
that's why it
exists so if you want to look at any
dysfunctional Behavior you have to
understand that at least for a very long
time and at least
partly it has succeeded in getting that
person what he or she wants that's why
it's persisted through time that's it
and if you were to change the operant
conditioning like the Rewards or
punishments as a consequence of that
behavior
consistently there're out you would very
quickly change that behavior that's the
only thing that
works so that's one reason why women
like [__] is because they don't bend
in ways that nice guys do that
ultimately lead to the disintegration of
the relationship and the attraction that
she felt for the guy to enter into the
relationship to begin
with um and this also extends to other
people out there it's it's sort of like
why does
why does the woman gravitate towards the
biggest scariest guy in the room often
because he's the safest one now you
might think well he sure doesn't look
safe with all of those tattoos
and and the the the leather jackets and
the kind of like growly stare well he
might not be safe to you another guy but
he's safe to her because she's thinking
if I'm with that guy no other guy's
gonna [__] with him so I want to be with
the guy that no other guy is GNA [__]
with and
[__] they fight
back they don't just say oh oh sorry uh
maybe I did something wrong there let's
let's work to friends you know get along
an [__] will be like go [__] yourself
man why would you do
that and they they they have don't have
a problem being
disagreeable and they don't have a
problem fighting for what they believe
in now some [__] are narcissistic
and what they believe in is just their
own misguided
self-interest but not all of them right
so but in any case they are willing to
fight for what they believe and what
they want and that's what makes them
more safe to women than guys who aren't
willing to
fight
uh [__] also often know that people
don't like them and they've developed a
kind of social callous around that which
gives them a social Freedom when you
talk to most guys the thing that
paralyzes them socially whether it's
with other guys at parties to make new
friends or with women picking them up is
they're afraid that they're going to
look awkward or they're going to say
something and people aren't going to
like them
but when you're an [__] people
already don't like you I mean what's the
[__] threat here you know what I'm
saying so because I'm used to
people not liking me because there are
people today right now who don't like me
and I can deal with it I have a social
Freedom that you
don't I can speak my truth because I
know what happens when people disapprove
or disagree with me and they hate
me not much
like they get all been out of sorts and
life goes
on [__] often get into trouble
because they all they also understand
that um rules are this is going to sound
shitty but rules
are really just
suggestions to maintain social cohesion
at the mass level but every rule has an
exception every rule was created by
people and so so every rule can actually
be undone by people as well an [__]
knows that uh it's not a virtue to
Simply uh follow a rule because it's a
rule like it has
to make sense it has to uh
support I guess his goals whether
they're personal or the social goals and
he doesn't mind necessarily
transgressing those rules from time to
time and getting into trouble because
trouble is not really a real Concept in
many
respects um some of the the darkest
moments that some of the people I look
up to have been in were
really were really ways for them to
launch their careers and their missions
to an even higher greater
level like when when Dr King was
arrested and thrown into the Birmingham
Jail do you really think that he was in
trouble I mean he has a mug shot he was
arrested there he was in jail in
handcuffs that's about as bad as it gets
in today's
society but it was an opportunity for
him to write some letters and it was
then a pivot point to D to draw even
more attention to a social cause which
generated even more
momentum trouble like a a master can use
anything to it to his
benefit trouble is wasted on those are
just the
unmas like nothing can go to waste to a
Master not not a crisis not a not a
disaster not a
disagreement anything can be used to
serve once you understand reality once
you have exper experience and expertise
and once you know what your purpose and
Mission is anything can be used to
further that you have nothing to fear so
I would say that in many respects that's
why women like
[__]
excellent fascinating talk let's take a
little break and I'll we'll continue
this and I'll post it in a week for
people that want want to hear more of ay
thank you all right thank
you